son combat judiciaire débute en 2007
paul françois un céréalier charentais
accuse alors non son taux de racheter en
2018 par l'allemand bayer d'être
responsable de son intoxication au lasso
un herbicide interdit en france en 2010
qui serait selon lui à l'origine des
troubles neurologiques dont il souffre
depuis son intoxication entre les deux
épandage j'ai voulu vérifier que le
nettoyage automatique des culs de mon
pulvérisateurs avait bien marché et
qu'elle était propre
dans l'une d'elles il restait un fonds
de l'assaut or ce que je ne savais pas
c'est que mélangée à l'eau est exposé au
soleil un des composants du lasso à
savoir du modo chlorobenzène devenait un
gaz très toxique sur l'étiquette du
produit
il était pourtant bien précisé que
l'utilisation du lasso ne nécessitait
pas de protection particulière
paul-françois attaque la firme pour ne
pas avoir à poser sur l'emballage du
produit deux mentions sur sa dangerosité
en 2012 le céréalier obtient gain de
cause en première instance puis en appel
trois ans plus tard mais en 2017
monsanto fait un pourvoi en cassation et
obtient l'annulation de cette décision
en avril 2019 monsanto bayer est à
nouveau tenu pour responsable des
dommages infligés à l'agriculteur sur la
base de je cite la responsabilité du
fait des produits défectueux
la cour de cassation a estimé que le
food membres de l'ue défaut
d'information sur l'étiquetage n'était
pas le bon mais qu'il s'agissait bien
plus d'une commercialisation d'un
produit défectueux
elle a alors demandé à la cour d'appel
de statuer sur ce nouveau fondement
en avril dernier cette dernière a de
nouveau condamné monsanto c'était notre
troisième victoire mais bailleurs ne
s'arrête pas là et se pourvoit à nouveau
en cassation en juillet 2019
la défense de monsanto bayer pointe du
doigt la négligence du céréalier
elle estime que ce dernier était au
courant de la dangerosité du produit
dans son arrêt voici ce que la cour
d'appel répondent les connaissances
techniques de ce dernier à les supposer
avérés ne pouvait pas y est le manque
d'informations sur le produit et ses
effets nocifs
un exploitant agricole n'étant pas un
chimiste l'arbitrage de la cour de
cassation devrait intervenir cette
semaine la cour d'appel de lyon
pourrait alors se prononcer sur les
éventuels dommages et intérêts réclamés
par l'agriculteur après avoir pointé la
négligence du céréalier bayer se dit
maintenant convaincus que le produit
n'est pas à l'origine des maladies a
légué de son côté paul françois espère
que cet arbitrage mettra définitivement
un terme à cette bataille judiciaire qui
s'éternise